wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ich finde es ja auch kalt aber
vertreiben sie nicht ein bisschen
übertreiben
ich kann es nicht verstehen wie man
diese lage kälte aushalten kann man
gewöhnt sich an das klima ich hoffe
woher kommen sie ich komme aus syrien
es ist natürlich meistens wärmer
november manchmal ist dass ich dich
kennen wir uns wie kann ich ihnen helfen
ich möchte vielleicht ein gebrauchtes
fahrrad kaufen und michael vorlegen
das heißt sie haben noch keines genau
aber meine tochter selma sie hat ein
fahrrad sie wird damit zur arbeit und
das ist günstiger als eine monatskarte
für die straßen waren
das verstehe ich zeige ihnen unsere
gebrachten weder ja vielen dank
[Musik]